lots of people I think struggle with
building a network because they think
about it as people knowing people how
many people do I know how many followers
have I got how many connections have I
got on LinkedIn that is like the sign of
a good Network and that's not that
meaningful that doesn't mean You' got a
good Network you might be connected to a
lot of people but it doesn't mean you've
got a good Community around your career
a good Community around your career is
one that is active and effective and so
we think about it as people helping
people cuz if I'm helping you that's
active here's some help it's an active
thing and you've been helped it is
effective so when we think about people
helping people as the basis for this it
starts to get a lot better and there's
two big benefits of it as well the first
is people like helping people like it's
a human trait like you get the helpers
high it's it's like proven that I if I
help you it makes me feel good and so
when people feel awkward about building
relationships starting with how you can
help and what you've got to give it just
feels
nicer